vamos a la revista de prensa con Marta
Moya Marta Buen día para usted buen
martes Ángela vamos a comenzar hablando
de chichimping esa visita de estado que
realiza a Moscú y que está ocupando un
papel central en los medios de
comunicación locales y también
internacionales Así es Ángela nos
centramos hoy en los medios chinos y
rusos porque está visita de estado pues
marca un punto de inflexión sobre todo
después de que se investirá por tercera
vez como presidente de China hemos
destacado en los dos principales o dos
de los principales medios Ruso y chino
empezamos con el global Times un partido
muy alineado con el partido comunista
que en su editorial destaca no Esta
visita de shinping a Moscú no Esta
visita de estado sostiene el global
Times da razones para creer que las
relaciones se van a intensificar con
Moscú No sólo en beneficios tangibles
para ambos pueblos sino en la promoción
de la paz y el desarrollo sostiene este
editorial el rol de china en las
relaciones internacionales marca esa
nueva esencia que quiere implementar el
gobierno de xiim basada en el respeto
mutuo la equidad la justicia y la
cooperación según este editorial Por
otra parte comentamos otro artículo de
conversan un medio ruso de los más
leídos en el país que dice que la
primera visita de jinping después de
invertir Seco de invertirse como
presidente marca la importancia de la
misma ambos líderes Putin y schimping
escribieron en los periódicos del otro
país Putin escribió en el Diario del
pueblo un artículo titulado Rusia y
China una asociación que Mira hacia el
futuro y si por su parte escribió para
la agencia de noticias
riano bosti la agencia rusa un artículo
que dice avanzar hacia nuevas
perspectivas de amistad y cooperación es
y desarrollo conjunto entre los dos
países la visita Eso sí despertó
rápidamente los recelos de Occidente
y no era ninguna sorpresa otro de los
actores indirectos de este encuentro y
cómo no es bolodimir zeledquí que podría
mantener su primera videollamada con el
mandatario chino desde el inicio de la
guerra el medio político habla sobre
este tema Si Ángela y político dice no
que al final selenski siempre tiende a
criticar con bastante facilidad a países
como Hungría o incluso Alemania por su
cercanía con Rusia sin embargo con el
principal Aliado vemos
siempre mantiene esa posición y ese tono
más diplomático kiev quiere mantener a
Beijing como un socio comercial y un
potencial intermediario para la
resolución del conflicto con Rusia y
además según sostiene político alejar la
posibilidad de que china exporte
armamento a Moscú a todo esto político
publicaba un artículo la semana pasada
en la que decía que obteniendo datos
aduaneros empresas chinas habían vendido
a empresas rusas al mil rifles de asalto
y otros materiales como piezas de drones
o chalecos antibalas con fines no se
sabe si militares china también puede
ayudar a Ucrania en la hipotética
reconstrucción del país una vez acá del
conflicto y además también sostiene este
artículo de político que ambos países
Ucrania y China no son ajenos no porque
antes de la guerra Ucrania y China o sea
es china Perdón era el principal Aliado
económico de Ucrania con inversiones En
infraestructura y sobre todo en el
mercado de los granos kiev además se
abstuvo en una votación de Naciones
Unidas en las que se condenaba pues la
represión de China contra el pueblo
yugurt pues se pone muy claro como China
tiene un papel preponderante en esta
etapa del conflicto sobre esto vamos a
hablar con el primer invitado del día
más adelante Marta pero vamos por ahora
a cambiar de tema aunque seguimos en
Ucrania el publica Este martes un
artículo en el que contrapone las
acerca de las últimas noticias de unas
explosiones que hubo en la Península de
crimea si Ángela y como siempre
versiones cruzadas e interesadas sobre
lo que pasa en el terreno nos referimos
a una explosión reportada de las últimas
horas en la ciudad de danacoy al norte
de la Península de crimea sobre todo
después de la visita de Vladimir Putin a
crimea este fin de semana con motivo del
noveno aniversario de la anexión las
versiones son Por una parte Ucrania no
ASUME su autoría directa pero dice que
esa explosión dejó un saldo no
especificado de misiles destruidos
mientras esto se transportaban por un
ferrocarril dices textualmente Ucrania
el algodón continúa el proceso de
desmilitarización de Rusia y prepara la
Península de crimea para la desocupación
O sea no la ASUME pero si queda estos
mimbres de el algodón que al final es
una referencia al humo que sale Y deja
en el cielo estas explosiones Por otra
parte Rusia dice que estas explosiones
se dieron por un ataque con drones a
infraestructura civil que dejaron Al
menos una persona herida y dañaron una
escuela una tienda de comestibles y
dañaron la parte de la red eléctrica del
país ninguna versión es así ha sido
verificada de manera independiente bueno
y sabemos que Ucrania insiste en
recuperar la Península de crimea Aunque
eso en los hechos poco se ha hablado
vamos a terminar con Estados Unidos o
con Donald Trump que vuelve a los
titulares desde este sábado cuando lanzó
la teoría de que hoy podría ser
arrestado por este caso tan polémico con
stormy daines sí Ángela pero al jazira
no se queda ahí no se queda solo en el
caso de la posible del posible soborno
por el caso de stornidenias un presunto
soborno de 130 mil dólares para que esta
actriz de cine adulto guardara silencio
después de que el ex mandatario hubiera
presuntamente tenido sexo con ella y la
hubiera obligado a callarse sino que
hayas ir hace un explainer de los demás
procesos judiciales que enfrenta Donald
Trump que no son pocos por ejemplo el
mal manejo de documentos clasificados El
asalto al Capitolio presentó fraude
electrónico Por recibir dinero para
presentar acusaciones falsas en el
proceso electoral de 2020 manipulación
de las elecciones en el estado de
Georgia difamación o un presunto fraude
en sus actividades económicas Así que
larga lista de investigaciones contadora
Trump pero las acusaciones vienen y
pasan por este caso que hoy se va a
dirimir en el estado de Nueva York y
nuestros televidentes pueden ir a
consultar todos los detalles en cada
medio que ustedes amablemente ha
mencionado Gracias Marta y nos vemos
mañana Gracias